all right welcome to the show it's my
last uh day in the bunker for a little
bit and there is much to discuss
and you know this this first story i'm
going to talk about there's sort of some
risk to even
talking about this story because
the issue of uh donald trump and russia
has become so weaponized and so
distorted
and so partisan and toxic and tribal
it's become so disconnected from the
actual facts that we know
that there's a risk to even bringing
this issue up again but there is news
that continues to fill out the story
and our understanding of what took place
before and during the trump
administration and we learned
some important things over the weekend
about coordination between the trump
2016
campaign and russian intelligence and
since we've covered the story all along
it would be weird if i didn't tell you
that there is
new information and there are some in my
audience i know
who uh refer to the story as russia gate
and refer to me as a russia gator
conspiracy hoax
whatever whatever the terms now are on
the story but
my my core audience who has been with us
you know at least back to 2017
knows that my position on trump russia
uh
was there will be no personal collusion
found
between donald trump and vladimir putin
at a personal level there's not going to
be any smoking gun video of trump and
putin
planning anything with regard to donald
trump's candidacy
but it looks like a duck and it sounds
like a duck and it walks like a duck
something approximating a duck is
probably there
and indeed we had more than a dozen
indictments in the molar probe
there was communication and coordination
between trump and russia including
through wikileaks as an intermediary
paul manafort in touch with russians
regarding polling and the campaign and
on and on
it was never going to remove donald
trump go back to my videos from april of
2017 where i made it clear
trump was never going to be charged or
end up in prison as a result of whatever
it was he did or didn't do with vladimir
putin because
i don't want to say no one believed but
our show was not saying
they will be caught having done anything
but it was likely
all along a combination of trump being
sort of a useful idiot
not even realizing how his mere
candidacy his mere presidency
helps russia's goal of destabilizing
western democracies for their gain
and some of the people around trump were
actually in touch with russians and
coordinating so
okay there's a new report and this is a
treasury department deport
report which now quietly
in 2021 years after the entire fiasco
with trump already gone confirms
that donald trump's 2016 campaign was
sharing information with a russian
intelligence officer
full stop that's the story during the
2016 election russian and ukrainian
political consultant
constantin kilimnik we've mentioned this
name before
was providing russia with so-called
sensitive
information on polling and trump
campaign
strategy kilimnik quote sought to
promote
uh the narrative that ukraine not russia
had interfered in the 2016 u.s
presidential election
in 2018 kilimnik was indicted on
obstruction of justice charges
for his unregistered lobbying work
related to ukraine
but this same treasury report now spells
out
that kilimnik had been coordinating with
donald trump's campaign chairman paul
manafort
during the 2016 election the treasury
report refers to kilimnik
as a russian intelligence officer donald
trump's campaign manager
campaign chairman for a period of time
was coordinating
with a man now regarded as described as
a russian intelligence officer and
manafort
repeatedly shared internal campaign
information
with kilimnik as mother jones writes
manafort passed inside info from the
trump campaign to kilimnik
kilimnik gave it to russian intelligence
which at the time
was mounting a covert attack on the 2016
election
to thwart hillary clinton and help
donald trump that's collusion
now it isn't the cartoonish scenarios
that some dreamed up
trump secretly meeting with putin
personally but it is trump's campaign uh
chairman
scheming with a russian intelligence
officer as russia was publishing
derogatory information
about trump's opponent hillary clinton
and preferred trump
over hillary we don't have to get all
dramatic
we don't have to get hyperbolic they
were working together
that's it it's simple meanwhile at the
same time
kilimnik was trying to use paul manafort
and through him use trump to advance
vladimir putin's interests related to
ukraine this isn't unique
many countries try to do this many of
them just
aren't as good as russia at doing it and
many countries don't have someone
as vulnerable and naive and ignorant
as donald trump and the people that
donald trump put around him and it
really went both ways
so for those who will react to this with
like an okay so what type of approach
imagine for a moment that it was
revealed today
for example it meant this hasn't
happened but imagine imagine we learned
today joe biden's campaign manager
was in regular contact with chinese
intelligence officers throughout the
2020 election including
unreported meetings passing internal
biden data
and strategy to chinese operatives who
by the way
were working on a campaign to hurt
donald trump how do you think
people would be reacting right now fox
news would be calling
for the removal and imprisonment of
treasonous trader
joe biden period and then also remember
that the mueller report basically said
the same things as the treasury report
that we now have
it used different language but just
before the mueller report was released
donald trump's hatchet man attorney
general william barr
put out that four-page propaganda letter
claiming to summarize what was in the
mueller report but not actually
summarizing it coming up with a
completely different
non-actually empirically based
assessment of what was in the report so
that led to the nationwide bogus
exoneration tour that donald trump went
on and the rest is sort of history so
that's the latest it's not really a
surprise
to anyone who has been paying attention
and
it will be ignored by those who are
convinced there was never anything there
uh but i i think that people who
followed the story
soberly and closely from the beginning
uh would not be shocked
nor would we think that it would be out
of line with what was going on at the
time
to get this report from the treasury
department
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman